What’s up, Wisecrack?
Helen again.
This summer, audiences got an arguably unnecessary
addition to one of cinema’s most perfect
trilogies with Toy Story 4.
The original three films about a band of spunky,
sentient children’s playthings grappled
with surprisingly deep questions about love,
loss, identity, being forgotten, moving on
and more.
This was a pinnacle achievement in children’s
cinema - in which sequels often feel like
clumsy, narratively gratuitous cash grabs.
So we went into this fourth film wondering
- is there really anything left for the series
to say, or are we just pandering to Randy
Newman fans at this point?
Let’s investigate in this Wisecrack Edition
on Toy Story 4: Deep or Dumb?
And, of course, spoilers ahead.
Alright guys, let’s dive into a recap.
Toy Story 4 starts with a flashback to the
young Andy days, as Woody watches Bo Peep
being given away.
She asks him to come with her, but he decides
“bros before Bo’s” and stays with Andy.
Flash forward to teenage Andy giving Woody
and co. to a hyperactive kid named Bonnie.
Even as Bonnie becomes increasingly less interested
in Woody, his loyalty leads him to follow
her to kindergarten, where he helps her create
Forky, which is exactly what it sounds like:
A spork with mismatched googly-eyes and pipe
cleaner arms.
Bonnie effing loves Forky, but Forky thinks
he’s trash and keeps trying end it all in
the nearest rubbish bin.
Woody has to prevent Forky from trashing himself
when Bonnie’s family heads out on an RV
trip.
Mishaps ensue, and Forky is promptly kidnapped
in an antique store by a sinister doll, Gabby
Gabby and her horrifying marionette minions.
Lost on a playground, a hapless Woody runs
into his old boo, Bo Peep, who is stanning
the “lost toy” lifestyle.
Together, the gang sets out on an elaborate
quest to rescue Bonnie’s beloved plastic
spork from Gabby Gabby.
Only it turns out Gabby Gabby just wants Woody’s
voice box to replace her defective one so
she can convince a little girl to love her.
Woody agrees to give up his voice box, the
marionette performs some quick black market
surgery, and, in exchange, Woody gets Forky
back.
Everything culminates at the carnival grounds
where Woody finds his calling as a Lost Toy
and decides that, this time, he’ll stay
with Bo.
They then devote themselves to helping toys
find their own way.
The end.
Now, Pixar is known for making some of the
best written and most thoughtful films out
there, and the Toy Story movies are no exception.
So we think it’s worth asking if Woody’s
emotional journey is about more than regretting
a breakup with a hot shepard.
We’ve come up with three possible interpretations
of the film to run by you guys.
Our first argument: Toy Story 4 is a tale
of existential awakening.
Briefly, Existentialism is a philosophy that
emphasizes individual free will and our power
to make choices that determine the course
of our lives.
The first three films have brushed against
existential themes, asking what it means to
be a toy who loves and is loved, or no longer
loved.
But in this fourth film it really goes there.
See, nearly every character in the film has
some kind of conflict with their “inner
voice” that governs their decision making
process.
Buzz struggles to make sense of his factory-issued
dialogue, while Woody grapples with his own
conscience to parse what he should do from
what he wants to do.
Meanwhile, Forky’s poor, plastic spork brain
insists that he is trash, and Gabby Gabby
longs to fix her voice box so she can speak
the words her toymakers intended her to.
To grasp how the inner voice speaks to a key
element of existentialism, we’re looking
to one bespectacled French philosopher Jean-Paul
Sartre.
Sartre believed that we are all radically
free and, because of that, it's up to us to
determine who we become based on our choices.
YOU choose the path you walk, the ice cream
flavor you eat, and the YouTube videos you
watch, algorithm be damned!
In his essay “Existentialism is a Humanism”,
Sartre famously wrote that “existence precedes
essence,” explaining that “first of all
man exists, turns up, appears on the scene,
and only afterwards, defines himself.”
Basically, there is no “essence” that
defines you from birth.
You first exist, then your essence is defined
by your choices.
You aren’t born the kind of person who wears
pleated khakis for fun, you become that when
you choose to wear your school uniform to
parties.
These choices define your character.
In this way, we can see Bo Peep as the consummate
existentialist.
She’s broken free from her obligations as
a toy belonging to children, and no longer
feels compelled to live by any outside creed.
This separation from the rules and expectations
of her past is symbolized in her freeing herself
from the lamp that she came with.
She runs amuck, exploring the world and playing
with whatever kids she wants.
Most importantly, she doesn’t blame anyone
for her choices - She is accountable to no
one and holds no one accountable for herself.
She is free.
The other characters are all struggling with
non-existential thinking - they define themselves
not by the individual choices they make, but
by their essence as toys as defined by their
quote unquote inner voice.
This is apparent in Woody’s single-minded
devotion to Bonnie.
He sees it as his duty to serve her, even
though she’s clearly no longer interested
in playing with him.
Regardless, he feels like he can’t make
the choice to be a toy without a kid.
Similarly, Forky sees himself as essentially
made from trash, and thus identifies entirely
as said trash, rather than a toy.
This line of thought is especially apparent
in the toys that were born “defective.”
For Gabby-Gabby, whose voice box doesn’t
work, her failure to fully embody her designed
functionality makes her sub par, and justifies
her sometimes-cruel actions.
Or take Duke Kaboom, who, in not being able
to jump through his hoop, failed to live up
to the impossible expectations set by his
commercials.
That failure, we see, has become an excuse
to do nothing with his life but weep and bemoan
what could have been.
For these two characters, their inability
to embody an aspect of their supposed essence,
haunts them.
They define themselves not by the choices
they make, but by a perceived lack with which
they were born, and thus are miserable.
Now, because Sartre believed that the choices
we make determine our essence, he also was
big on the idea of personal responsibility
- or as he puts it:
This might sound fun at first - don’t we
all want to be in control of our own lives
and eat ice cream for breakfast?
It’s not that simple though - because a
dude’s choices determine his destiny, he
“is responsible for everything he does.”
So when you get cavities, you have nobody
to blame but yourself.
As a result, Sartre doesn’t see freedom
as a fun walk in the park - in fact, he writes
that “man is condemned to be free.”
A lot of people find that freedom hard to
take, which is why, you know… cults.
This conflict around accepting personal responsibility
for your choices is probably best embodied
by Buzz Lightyear.
Whenever he’s faced with a tough decision,
Buzz presses one of his buttons and waits
for his “programming” to issue a command
- calling this his “inner voice.”
Rather than take responsibility for his choices,
he simply outsources them.
This can occasionally help him get out of
a jam:
“What would Woody do?”
“Eh, jump out of a moving vehicle.”
“There’s a secret mission, in uncharted
space, let’s go!”
but doesn’t always yield the most helpful
advice:
“Scanning perimeter.”
“Lasers at full power-”
“Buzz, what are you doing?”
“I’m thinking.”
This is also reflected in Woody’s preoccupation
with his inner voice.
While Buzz’s inner voice was literally manufactured
by a factory, Woody’s was developed after
years of believing that a toy only exists
for the joy of a kid.
As a result, he sees his duties as clearly
defined: He has to help Bonnie however he
can.
As he puts it:
“I need to do this that little voice inside
me would never leave me alone if I gave up.”
This is despite the fact that Bonnie’s really
over him.
Here, we could say that Woody is acting in
“bad faith” or what Sartre would refer
to as the state of pretending that you’re
not free.
In a burn-happy quote, Sartre says:
In the first scene of the film, Woody pretends
that he doesn’t have the freedom to leave
Andy behind and run away with Bo Peep.
Sartre would say that he does, and the only
thing that stopped him was his choice not
to.
Throughout the course of the film, we watch
as each character basically becomes…, through
a Sartrean lens, kind of, really human?...
coming to terms with their own autonomy and
freedom to make choices.
That’s right, toys are resolving their existential
crises onscreen, what have you done today?
Most importantly, Woody chooses to stay with
Bo Peep, thus embracing his radical freedom
and rejecting his supposed essential “purpose”
of being a child’s plaything.
Even though leaving his child behind once
seemed unfathomable, he realizes that he can,
and so, he does.
Existential crisis averted!
Importantly, Buzz too has his own free will
affirmed during a critical moment - He needs
Bonnie to bring the family back to the antique
store to rescue Woody and Forky, but she just
won’t notice that she left her backpack
behind.
After his buttons fail to guide him, he uses
his own voice:
“Your backpack is in the antique store,
let’s go!”
“Oh no!
My backpack!”
Here, Buzz recognizes that he can’t rely
on his factory-issued “inner voice,” and
is forced to take action to save the day-
to make a choice.
When we first meet GabbyGabby, she has an
almost religious attachment to her own mythos,
reading her illustrated companion book as
if its a biblical text and treating tea-time
with her inattentive “God”, Harmony, as
if it is a spiritual rite.
Her life is defined by her desire to please
Harmony, and she goes to extraordinary lengths
to do so.
But then, even when her voice box is fixed,
she's still rejected by her, and the narrative
in the book is proven false.
With the help of Woody and Bo, she learns
that she’s not at the mercy of the Gabby
Gabby mythos- that it’s up to her to define
herself and her worth through the choices
she makes.
Similarly, Sartre’s whole schtick is predicated
on the belief that God does not exist.
Because there is no bearded dude in the sky
controlling our lives, it must be up to us
to choose our own path.
When Gabby Gabby encounters the lost little
girl at the fair, she chooses to offer herself
up for adoption.
Sure, she’s submitting to the ownership
model that Woody’s about to leave behind,
but she’s openly choosing it over the alternative.
Similarly, Ducky and Bunny, the lovable Key
and Peele carnival toys go from wanting to
passively be chosen by a child who will love
them to becoming super-active freedom fighters,
busting other stuffed animals out of the carnival-booth
purgatory they loathed.
Meanwhile, Duke Kaboom, at the urging of Woody
and Bo, chooses to leap on his motorcycle,
first four feet then forty, in spite of the
fact that he won’t land perfectly like he’s
supposed to in the commercial.
He’s learned to no longer live by the standards
dictated by his design.
That, friends, is called freedom.
And we can’t forget Forky - easily the weirdest
character in the Toy Story canon.
Early on, Forky identifies as trash - he was
made to be a spork, and should have wound
up in the warm, warm embrace of the garbage:
“I am not a toy, I’m a spork!”
“Be quiet!”
“ I was made for soup, salad, maybe chili,
and then the trash!
I’m litter, freedom!”
However, with the help of Woody, he realizes
that he isn’t a slave to his inner voice
- He can establish a new identity as a toy
who is loved by Bonnie.
He’s so thoroughly inculcated to his own
freedoms that, by the end of the film, he’s
even prepared to pass on some of that existential
wisdom to his new love interest.
“We are all toys.
Unique, beautiful, toys.”
Each character’s narrative arc shows them
grow from a character who accepts the destiny
thrust upon them, to an almost eerily human-like
being who makes choices that have consequences,
and thus exhibits autonomy over their own
existence.
That’s pretty beautiful.
We’d grade this interpretation a cool A,
and say that, viewed through this lens, the
film is deep with a capital D.
So now that we’ve gotten the existential
mind-fuck out of the way, its time for our
second interpretation: that Bo Peep is the
Miltonian Satan.
I know.
Hear us out.
In the world of these toys, children are basically
God-like creatures who they spend their lives
serving.
They live their lives for their children,
just as a religious person might live their
life for God.
In fact, the god-liness of children in this
world is made pretty literal with the introduction
of Forky, an inanimate object who Bonnie,
through the sheer power of childish wonder,
whimsy and a couple of googly-eyes, brings
to life.
It’s also worth noting the almost religious
reverence that the toys have for their children:
“No, I can’t, sir.
Bo, I need to get back to my kid.”
“What!
You got a kid?”
“Yeah…”
“Way to beat the odds, soldier.”
Recall the way Gabby Gabby reads her book
like a bible.
Similarly, Duke spends all his time bemoaning
the way he let down his former child owner,
and when he performs a life-threatening stunt,
it is his child’s face that appears to him,
like a divine mirage.
In this context, Bo Peep has committed the
ultimate sin: she’s rejected children, and
in doing so, rejected God.
In John Milton’s famous epic Paradise Lost,
a prideful Satan is depicted as being cast
out from heaven and condemned to Hell after
a failed rebellion against God.
He didn’t accept God’s dominion over him,
and thought all angels should rule as Gods
themselves.
Similarly, Bo Peep didn’t want to belong
to a child anymore, she wanted to be her own
master.
When she and Woody reunite after years, he
assumes that she must be devastated not to
have a child.
Instead, she seems free, almost ecstatic.
Perhaps fittingly, moments earlier, the pair
fall down a hill - Is it a stretch to see
this then, as Woody’ satanic-like “fall”
from his role as the eternally devout toy?
Hmm… maybe.
There’s more though: Satan is practically
defined by his predilections as a tempter.
In Goethe’s Faust, a devil tries to convince
Faust to sell his soul in exchange for all
worldly pleasures, telling him to:
Similarly, Bo Peep lures Woody away from the
quiet, safe world he has known all his life.
She embodies temptation, compelling Woody
with promises of exciting carnivals and far-flung
lands.
If we do take this interpretation seriously,
it’s also worth noting the fun reversal
of traditional Christian imagery - Bo Peep
is a shepherd, just like Jesus… except she’s
leading toys away from the flock.
She’s really the anti-shepherd encouraging
everyone to go their own way in life, free
of the responsibility they all feel to their
sometimes-unappreciative children.
Now before you raise your eyebrows too high,
know that we’d only grade this interpretation
a square C+.
If you can’t quite picture Bo Peep wearing
devil horns, that’s ok.
We’ve got one more interpretation for you.
We see some definite psychological complexes
exhibited by Forky and it helps explain why
he desperately wants to bathe in trash.
To understand this, let’s look at Sigmund
Freud and Otto Rank.
Now, Freud describes birth, or leaving the
womb, as the "first experience of anxiety
and thus the source and prototype of ... anxiety.”
His one-time colleague Otto Rank took it further,
suggesting that birth isn’t just anxiety-inducing…
it’s actually traumatic, the greatest trauma
of life, in fact.
Think about it - you go from the reasonably
chill, quiet world of your mom’s womb (sorry)
to a weird outside world where your mom’s
screaming, fluorescent lights are shining
and then some doctor spanks your butt.
Not the kind of activity you want to repeat.
So now consider that Forky’s “birth”
of sorts took place in the kindergarten classroom
when he was clumsily pieced together by Bonnie
from disparate pieces of trash.
As indicated by the first noise he makes when
he becomes vocal,
“Ahhhhhhh!”
Forky’s birth seems to have been at least
a little traumatic.
Rank notes that the resulting trauma from
birth leads us to long for a return to our
primal state, noting that “every pleasure
has as its final aim the re-establishment
of the intrauterine primal pleasure.”
Basically, we have a desire to return to the
womb, even though we definitely would not
fit anymore.
As a result, we experience infantile regression,
which means that we’ll seek out replacements
for our mom’s womb in various objects or
other people, which a Freudian might say is
the reason a Freudian might say is the reason
you enjoy jacuzzis, sorry.
Anyway, we see some hardcore infantile regression
coming from Forky, who desperately seeks to
return to his own “womb,” which is to
say, the trash.
In what becomes one of the film’s funniest
bits, Forky gleefully throws himself into
every trash can he can find.
He reverently calls out for trash the way
a child might call out for their own mother,
and exhibits the same kind of clingy longing
that a newborn might.
When Woody asks him why he’s so obsessed
with trash cans, he gives an answer that would
certainly raise Otto Rank’s eyebrow:
“It’s warm…”
“Ew.”
“And cozy…”
“I guess.”
“And safe!
Like somebody’s whispering in your ear ‘Everything’s
gonna be okay.’”
If that’s not infantile regression, I don’t
know what is!
Okay but real talk, we’ll give Forky’s
garbage womb interpretation a solid C.
Now, whether or not you buy any of these ways
of reading the film, I think we can all agree
that Pixar created another extremely thoughtful,
emotionally powerful film with Toy Story 4.
And at least for our favorite reading, it
seems like the geniuses at Pixar have created
a toy-sized mirror for some of the anxieties
we may be facing in an increasingly secular
world.
But what do you guys think?
Do you buy that Toy Story is an existentialist
saga, or do you think it’s more in line
with our not-so-secret desire to crawl back
into a nice big womb?
Let us know in the comments.
As ever, a big ole thanks to our wonderful
patrons who sponsor our show and podcasts.
Be sure to click that subscribe button and,
as always, peace!